foreign
here's what's happening Jade people see
these headlines and it makes them spiral
even further about the economy and they
it gets political yeah and there's a lot
of reasons for these food prices
skyrocketing supply chain issues still a
problem Transportation costs it just
costs more to move things across the
country yeah there's Global factors I
mean there's a war happening I don't
know if you've heard about it with
Russia and Ukraine uh bird flu that
happened which is causing a lot of these
these egg prices I don't want to focus I
can't change that I can't change the War
I can't change the bird flu I can't
change supply chain but what I can do is
I can meal plan you can change that
budget I can change my budget if I can't
afford eggs I need to cook stuff that
has less eggs in it right I can
absolutely control the controllables
right and I love this meal planner on
ramseysolutions.com uh that you can take
a look through it's yeah Rachel Cruz
produced this and it's been updated but
at the time you know we didn't
experience all this inflation now we
need this and so you get this incredible
guide at ramseysolutions.com meal
planner and it also includes a grocery
savings guide there's some templates you
can print out for meal planning grocery
shopping there's a ton of tips in there
and it's completely free for you you can
also check out our article on why food
prices are going up we've got all of
that for you in the show notes as well
if you're watching the show listening to
the show but there are some things we
can do and we've mentioned some of them
on the show before but doing your
research not just buying willy-nilly
impulsively but actually researching
where the best spots are to go what's on
sale that week using what you already
have that's right you don't want to
reach back in that pantry and go oh that
that went bad you know George January is
a great month to do a pantry challenge
yes and just cook all that stuff in
there you got black beans in there you
got some old blue box macaroni and
cheese in there you have some old
noodles that get creative yeah get
creative you better fix those noodles
fix them they don't go bad
there's on top of that of course buying
generic brands we know you love your
name brand this or that it's the same
thing generic it's made in the same
Factory they just slap a different label
on it and one of the hardest things
switching where you Shop grocery wise
that one is emotional for some people
yeah you know you know where everything
is in every aisle it's very comforting
but if you can save 20 30 40 50 bucks by
going to Aldi worth it do it and then
freezing your meals a lot of times food
goes bad because you just let it sit and
so freeze that junk George if you look
in my freezer you're gonna see a single
hot dog bun Frozen you're gonna see
she's freezing everything you're gonna
see a clove of garlic that's been frozen
you're gonna see an individual veggie I
freeze everything wow my friends make
fun of me but trust trust and believe
the time will come when you want to make
a hot dog and you need that hot dog bun
or thawing it out in 2023 God help
that's the advice that's the slogan and
of course if you're not budgeting you
gotta start because it's one of the main
reasons you're feeling the pinch you're
not paying attention to where your
money's going doing yes you need to make
some sacrifices but you have to know
where to make those sacrifices and
understand what you're currently
spending yeah and we've got a great app
for you called every dollar to help you
do that I love every dollar I love every
dollar because I never just put like a
food line item it's like a grocery store
household items restaurants if there's a
holiday you know Thanksgiving you know
whatever the holiday is I love being
detailed in that because that's where
you really see how you're spending right
absolutely lunch if you buy lunch at you
know at work you know oh yeah now might
be the time to stop that's all I'm
saying we've got a cafeteria here at
Ramsey Solutions and that can be
dangerous I'm much less likely to meal
prep every day oh yeah you know I've
been rolling through there getting
smoothies so I need to chill out an
incredible benefit but something else
I've done Jade because a lot of people
you know I posted that very
controversial Instagram reel and Tick
Tock saying hey it's cheaper to eat at
home yes than to eat out people freak
they got pitchforks George you are in
danger well what about all the my time
is that not worth anything thing I gotta
cook I gotta clean I'm using all these
pots and pans they're arguing with me
about the time it takes these people
need to choose because you can't hear
George
but both ways all right you can't go out
here on this side and complain about
food prices and gas prices and this and
this and get all mad about everything
and then when we tell you hey here's a
way to make your life better just simply
XYZ you know start budgeting start
cutting back start look you know and
then you say no I don't want to do that
either I and it gets into that that
mindset of I deserve I don't have to do
anything I don't have to do anything to
change my situation I don't have to do
anything to make my personal life in my
home at my house better I just get to
Rave and complain about politics about
supply chain about tipping about
everything else I don't have to do
anything to change well what's funny to
me is there's throwing Instagram reels
to troll me in the comments they could
have uh used that time to cook you could
cook your meal if your time is worth
that much what are you doing on social
media bub you could have cooked a whole
hot dog there you go and ate it at home
and it would have cost you if it was a
Costco hot dog a dollar fifty but I'm
just saying they're holding down the
line Costco was speeding inflation
single-handedly if you want to change
this you make changes here's the
question simple hot dogs are up 16
what's in that hot dog Costco I got a
lot of questions how are you doing this
it's meat pieces George it's not real
meat well you love cramping so we can't
trust you now Jade goodness gracious
well hope those tips help go to
ramseysolutions.com meal planner you can
check that out hope it helps you all
fight this wild wild inflation this is
the Ramsay show